here's the first story from the Daily
Mail Tucker Carlson tells Russell Brand
he doesn't know why he was fired by Fox
News in his first interview as he also
makes the bombshell claim that the crowd
outside the capitol on January 6 was
filled with federal agents well in fact
we have that clip green lives matter not
true who that is other than
they have a good amount of followers and
they tweeted this Tucker says the chief
of Capitol Police told him that the
crowd on January 6 was filled with
federal agents he planned on airing that
interview but was canceled before he
could do so now we know why he was
canceled and fired are you seeing it
clearly now they don't want the world to
know the truth well let me play for you
that clip it's only about 50 seconds
long and that was a tip off to me I mean
I had no thought in my head as I watched
this happen on television and in the
subsequent weeks that U.S
law enforcement or military agencies had
anything to do with it that never
crossed my mind I never thought there
was it was a false flag or anything like
that I'm not a conspiracist by
temperament I never thought that
um and then I interviewed the chief of
the Capitol Police
Steven's son in an interview that was
never aired on Fox by the way I was
fired before could air
um I I'm going to interview him again
but Stevenson was the totally
non-political
worked for Nancy Pelosi I mean this was
not some right-wing activist he was the
chief of the Capitol Police on January
6th and he said oh yeah yeah that crowd
was filled
with federal agents what yes well he
would know of course because he was in
charge of security at the site
so the more time has passed now it's
been so that's that's the the gist of it
I mean this is
it's big news but I I do think it's
going to be better when Tucker does
actually interview the chief of police
and we hear it straight from you know
this individual who's in charge of
security but uh yeah I would imagine
he's gonna prompt uh you know actually
deliver that promise as well getting
that out there because that'll just be I
mean pretty much confirming a lot of
what people have been saying right after
January 6. I don't know if you guys
remember but I mean obviously this was
right after uh the summer of love and
everything like that in a a major
narrative just from people was uh well
Trump supporters don't really move like
that this seems a little bit off this
seems suspicious it seems as though the
more time that's passing by the more
this stuff is just getting exposed every
single month
the scary thing I suppose is it's it's
it's it's trickling in drops at a time
yeah you know we we see videos of some
guy saying like go go go move and
encouraging people to engage in this
stuff then we learn that there's more
and more police officers who ran on the
funny thing is early on you had uh you
have that famous video with AOC where
she's like I'm you know questioning the
cops who may have been involved or she
said something that effect after uh Alex
Stein did that big booty latina thing
she was saying like we don't feel safe
and stuff and the point I made was wow
AOC is claiming it was an inside job but
there's videos of cops opening the doors
for people waving people in taking
selfies with people so right there you
could argue yeah the cops were letting
people in if this was really an
Insurrection well they were police
officers letting them in yeah now
there's a bigger question and
increasingly more and more news being
added to the mix which is creating a
bigger picture of actually there were
people in the crowd encouraging it and
making it happen the reason why I say
it's scary is that it's coming out only
in slow droplets to the point where
people don't care because it's not a
bombshell yeah yeah just drop as many a
thousand stories over the next handful
years and like you said not a big
bombshell I think for the general
General like population as well they
don't grab on to the little tiny hints
and Clues here and there they really
grab onto major Bombshells so if I went
out and on the street and talked to
people about you know these details that
have been coming out most people don't
know about this stuff they only know
about major major explosions in the
media and then assuming that the
mainstream media even covers it and then
by the time we're at the general
election next year it will be common
knowledge that it was largely a federal
operation and they'll be saying it was a
good thing yeah it saved the election
help save democracy yeah first they'll
say first I said it wasn't happening
you're lying now we have more
information it was then they're going to
say oh well you're exaggerating and then
by next year it'll be a good thing
that's how the cycle goes and they'll be
like oh yeah it happened yeah and it was
a really good thing that it did because
they caught those evil people for sure
for sure yeah they they prevented a
Siege by letting them inside and
capturing them on the inside what would
the argument don't make what would have
happened if they if they tried to block
him I mean it would have been real maybe
they would burn it down you know so by
opening the door oh yeah and encouraging
him to do it was to find out who was
really going to be a a seditionist and
et cetera et cetera blah blah blah I was
thinking a lot about these these
protesters last night and like they were
addressing grievances they didn't
believe the election was fair and they
were trying to stand their ground and
take space to prevent the signing of
basically the of Biden of the election
they were like of you know whatever they
were signing off and making it valid
they were like no we're gonna stay here
so you can't they weren't like attacking
people or choking people Ashley Babbitt
got shot because she went a little too
far I think she she climbing up in over
the barricade going into the inner
Chambers got shot I understand why I
don't like it but they were like just
taking up space right not to mention
that had been done all over the place
for the last however many hundreds of
days like we watched in the Summer of
Love so they're like well I mean
why can't we do this as well well they
they even try to sell it as an armed
Insurrection like they will go that far
uh I talk to people about this all the
time and they will go that far to be
like oh well some guy across the parking
lot was caught with a a firearm on his
person or something like that therefore
now they can say it's an arm to
Insurrection like I was there man I was
I was reporting on the thing I was there
uh not inside I saw a lot of people and
it's like it was nothing like any right
you've ever seen it was it was okay some
people misbehaving over here you look to
your right and it's like 15 grandmas
praying I think there was uh there's a
photo of a guy who's on the stairs and
he's got a gun on him was he a Fed now
I'm starting to wonder this is exactly
the point well there's tens of thousands
of people there too so here's the issue
is that I remember seeing these photos
circulate mainly among the left a lot of
people in the right didn't know this
even I was wrong about this early on
when I was like there were no guns
already talking about how could you have
a gun in DC yeah they found a couple and
they did and now that we're learning
that there were law enforcement there
it's like oh now that kind of explains
it doesn't right it's like were those
guys because the question is how how do
you get a firearm onto these ground into
the city under these grounds with
heightened security and stuff like that
how did they not spot this or find it
it's entirely possible I'm not saying
I'm not saying that they were law
enforcement totally possible some guy
did bring up bring a gun you it you can
walk in you can find ways to bypass
security uh or it could just be the
photo they found of that guy was because
I don't think that guy's been charged
either well and that's where it's like
okay you raise a very reasonable
question your question is who is that
and even that gets criticized it's oh
stop that stop you you're a conspiracy
theorist don't have this conversation
don't get more specific don't show more
footage don't educate people I should
clear it up too they weren't all I don't
think they were all just standing there
taking up space some of them were
getting violent pushing cops pushing
breaking things you're right yeah so
those people I think deserve to be
punished for what they did not for
anything I mean you can't just fight
police and just get away with it unless
you're a BLM protester right
it's not that much to ask to say you
know at least treat people fairly but
the same way that you would that they
treated the other protesters in DC and
six months earlier but this is the point
that Carter was making for sure you have
the Summer of Love protests in riots in
front of the White House setting fire to
St John's Church forcing the president
to a bunker and
the the half the people on January 6
were nowhere near that level for sure
there's so you know right injured uh
Secret Service as well they destroyed
multiple Patrol Vehicles like 100 or
something Secret Service were injured a
guard post was that was that on fire and
burned down right outside the barricades
were torn down yep the president was
forced into a bunker and so you get
people who are Marching peacefully to
the capital and first I always preface
it on one side violence very very bad
writing yep arrest those people and then
another side you had the cops open the
doors and say don't don't agree with it
but respect it and fan people into the
point where there have been acquittals
because there's video the cops going
like this and waving people in so you're
a guy watching Trump speak and then
someone says hey let's all go March down
to the capital and Trump says we're
gonna go peacefully uh you know uh watch
politicians you walk over you see a
building you see the cops waving people
and you walk in and they're like you are
now going to prison for the next several
years that charge or trial because
you're an insurrectionist after you just
watched all these videos of the far left
going to burn down a church in front of
the White House talk about it's not even
hypocrisy or double standard who who was
it who said Jacob maybe there's it's a
three-tier justice system yeah he did he
said it on the show when he was guest
hosting ah there's the protected class
then there's the random run-of-the-mill
people they care a little about and the
persecuted class so if you're a regular
person who's walking down the street you
may or may not get a ticket they're
going to ignore you it's whatever if
you're a leftist extremist not only will
you be acquitted like in DC when they
were riding during Trump's inauguration
they won a lawsuit and got paid out by
tax dollars and then if you're a trump
supporter you will bumble around
confused and you'll be in prison for two
years or if you're even perceived to be
a trump supporter or whatever like Eric
Herrera he went to prison for actually
I'll first say he was a non-credentialed
journalist went in there with a you know
camera in into the Capitol Building
non-violent no nothing violent that he
did and he went to prison for four years
prison for four years and I think he
went in maybe three months ago
non-violent you you can even check out
his case what was he charged with uh so
what they got a lot of these people with
and I you know I'm not going to be I'm
not a total professional on this but I
will say uh when it comes to the charges
what they were getting people with was
obstruction of an of an official
proceeding that's what they got them on
that is what they were doing even though
he was there being a a journalist
literally with a DSLR around his neck um
I believe he like went into one of the
offices and held up a piece of paper I'm
pretty sure it says that on his case but
he got four years you can compare that
to I mean how many how many how many BLM
or antifa uh members can you compare
that to from riots that did something 15
20 30 times worse that that served way
less time that's insane there are
absolutely many leftists who have been
criminally charged they've they often
get ridiculously light sentences there
was just news about people at a Michael
Knowles event some far left ex leftists
with explosives they've been criminally
charged you have those two lawyers in
New York who are giving out fire bombs
and what did they get like a year I
think they got like maybe two they
definitely got less than Eric I know
that and we had Matt Brenner in the show
talk about this bard
I would imagine so but I I I mean I
would even really like to know if they
got disbarred I would imagine yeah I
mean I would imagine too but I wouldn't
be shocked if we found out they didn't
though but uh Matt Brainerd was on the
show just a couple days ago and he
mentioned that there's a guy and
probably more than one that is currently
in jail without charge or trial two and
a half years later not charged with
anything so you ask what did they get
these people on well in some cases
nothing thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time